Ariana greenblat alting as a young Jedi
Ahsoka Tano isn't the first time that
she's played a younger version of a
formidable hero in a hugely popular
franchise prior to starring on aoka she
portrayed young Gamora in Avengers
Infinity War featuring in a pair of
scenes alongside Josh Brolin Thanos what
did it
cost everything hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie Barbie is arguably a generation
defining Blockbuster Ariana Green blads
plays a standout part in the movie of
Sasha an angsty gen Z teen who lost
interest in playing with dolls a long
time ago Sasha is one of the main human
characters in Barbie the titular doll
comes to the human world to find Sasha's
mother Gloria and a scrunt Mattel
employee who's trying to find her
purpose in life initially though Barbie
think she's coming to help the teen
Sasha and Gloria don't always see eye to
eye and their relationship is at the
heart of some of the film's funniest and
most dramatic scenes are you really
going to let Barbie take you and your
tween daughter to an imaginary land yes